Britain's Prince Harry is denouncing the
photographers who chased after Princess
Diana the night she was killed
he speaks out in a new BBC documentary
about the accident in Paris and the
extraordinary reaction twenty years ago
next week Harry and his brother Prince
William appear in the documentary
Jonathan Vigliotti is outside Kensington
Palace in London where Diana and her
children lived Jonathan good morning
good morning at some of the most
scathing criticism to come from
Kensington Palace Princess Diana's sons
taking direct aim at the paparazzi
calling them a pack of dogs 20 years
after his mother's tragic death an angry
Prince Harry points fingers I think one
of the hardest things to come to terms
with is the fact that the people that
chased her through the into the tunnel
were the same people that were taking
photographs of her while she was still
dying on the back seat of the car in the
new documentary Prince Harry now only
blamed the paparazzi for the crash that
killed his mom but said they stood by
and watched her die she'd had a quite a
severe head injury but she was very much
still alive on the back seat and those
people that that caused the accident
instead of helping we're taking
photographs of her dying on the back
seat and then those photographs made
have made their way back to two news
desks dozens of photographers chased
after the car Princess Diana was in just
before it lost control inside a Paris
tunnel 20 years ago
the driver was under the influence of
drugs and alcohol at the time Ken Wharf
Princess Diana's former bodyguard said
her own security could have done more to
prevent the deadly cat-and-mouse pursuit
why don't we give them a photo call you
know Dinah had given millions of photo
opportunities in her life
and part of the problem in Paris was
this desire by the gathering media
circus for a picture nearing the
anniversary of Diana's death the
what-ifs still persist it'll either make
or break you and I wouldn't let it break
me
Prince William simply called it the
hardest moment of his life I wanted her
to be proud of the person I would become
I didn't want her worried or her legacy
to be that you know William and Harry
were completely devastated by William
and Harry said they specifically waited
for the 20th anniversary to talk so
openly about their mother's death and
Gale Prince William even said we won't
be doing this again yeah they have said
that that this is it they're talking now
but it's very touching I think that
they're sharing such personal things
with us and how painful it must be guys
for Harry to say the people that were
taking their mother's picture while she
was dying we're feeding that picture to
the media instead of helping their
mother what that has to do to you and
what do you think yeah the paparazzi and
they see those maybe not the same people
but paparazzi Jonathan Vigliotti
reporting from London we thank you again